the cdc has just released some great
news in the fight against kovid
72 000 americans have undied of of covid
19.
now i am certain these people did not
come back to life
and i'm pretty sure that these people
never died in the first place but the
one thing that i now know for sure
is that they did not die of covid
last week
without really much of any explanation
the cdc lowered the total covid death
count
by a lot not just by a few people stray
numbers here or there they lowered it by
more than 72 000
that includes around 24
of pediatric deaths
when asked how they got the count
so
incredibly wrong
the agency blamed the algorithm
they said oopsie daisy
a coding logic error
caused the artificially high number
now if you had suggested
if you had maybe just raised the
possibility that possibly the official
covid death numbers were being
exaggerated over the past two years
you would have been accused of spreading
dangerous misinformation you could have
been kicked off of social media kicked
out of the public square you would have
been called a danger to society you
would have been called a murderer
you would have been blamed for other
people's deaths you would have been
right
but
that wouldn't have mattered because the
definition of misinformation today
according to big tech and even our
government is so broad
that it even includes true information
if that information is inconvenient to
the political goals of our ruling class
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from robert lanham
who says michael we should put up giant
billboards in response to the gay
democrat billboard in florida that
plainly say hunter biden laptop another
effective marketing strategy pioneered
by the left and perfected by the right
well we would do that except for this
one problem in florida they say that
you're not allowed to say gay but of
course you really are allowed to say gay
and
throughout the rest of the country they
say that you're allowed to say hunter
biden laptop but you are most certainly
not allowed to say hunter biden laptop
certainly not when there's an election
afoot absolutely not then you can't
tweet it you can't post it you can't
even privately message it
because our government is clamping down
and when there's a lot of political
turmoil it is good to have tangible
assets which is why you've got to check
out birch gold right now text knolls to
989898 with inflation at seven percent
like it is now thanks to joe biden's
stupid economic policies that paper
money in your wallet is losing value
fast today an ounce of gold is worth
nineteen hundred bucks it was worth
about three hundred dollars per ounce in
two thousand
i have been telling you for years that
you can buy gold from birch gold it is
your hedge against inflation did you
know there's another way to hedge
against inflation it's not just gold you
can also buy silver from birch gold
silver is also considered real money and
historically speaking it is extremely
undervalued right now it's an industrial
metal that is in high demand for
everything from electric cars to solar
panels silver light gold is never going
to zero the american dollar well it's
going down the drain right now while
precious metals are rising in value
thanks to the fed call birch gold right
now
they're the only company i trust for
this kind of thing do not wait start
diversifying text knolls k w l e s to 9
8 9 8 9 8 to get a free info kit on
buying gold or silver in a tax sheltered
account there's no obligation to get
this info text knowles kwles get the
info kit right now text it to 989898
i
did not believe
that the official
of
misinformation disinformation all the
words they use to say fake news i did
not believe
that the official definition included
true information
i thought that was just one of those
right-wing crazy talking points
and then i found the sysa website
you've got to check this out for
yourself you go to saisa this is the
cyber security and infrastructure
security agency cisa
dot gov
and they've got a page on mdm that's
miss
dis
and mal information
often all these were mal information was
a new one to me but these words will be
used interchangeably but there are
subtle distinctions between them they
say sizes miss dis and mal-information
mdm team is charged with building
national resilience to mdm and foreign
influence activities and so they go out
and they are basically a propaganda arm
of the us government that tries to
counter other information that they deem
dangerous or false or just
politically inconvenient
they they give definitions of these of
these various terms so they'll say
mal information and this is the one
they're really focused on it's the top
announcement march 15th starting today
saiza is launching a new mdm social
media series optical illusions to raise
public awareness of mdm and more
specifically mal information what is mal
information mal information is based on
fact
but used out of context to mislead harm
or manipulate and so saiza this agency
of the government is going to going to
inform you about mal information
in other words mal information
is true information
that our political ruling class
doesn't want people to believe
it's what you see in all of the quote
unquote fact-checking websites
which are really just left-wing
operative websites that are putting
forward left-wing opinions and then
declaring them true or false and then
using their power with social media
platforms with big tech with the entire
liberal apparatus to suppress
information they don't like
so they'll say
you know
we saw this just a few weeks ago with
the bio labs we said there were
the claim was there are u.s funded
biobiological research facilities in
ukraine funded not just by the us but by
the u.s military
and what you saw in all the
fact-checking websites was fake fake
news false ten thousand pinocchios it's
not true
and then if you read the articles they
would say no actually it is true these
laboratories exist we've been funding
them since 2005. the military is
actually funding them blah blah blah
blah blah
but
it's out of context 10 pinocchios 10 000
it's
the russians are pushing this the
chinese are pushing this so even though
it's true we're going to call it fake
news and then because these fact
checkers have so much influence on the
algorithms
if you report on that true information
you will have your website suppressed
your view suppressed you'll be shadow
banned it will not work mal information
pay attention that word is going to play
a much bigger role moving forward
because we've just come out of two years
of hearing about misinformation there's
more than two years actually really
really kicking into high gear at the
beginning of the trump presidency you
heard this is everything that you're
hearing that is contrary to the
democrats is distant rut misinformation
disinformation that hunter biden laptop
51 intelligence officers said oh it's
this is classic russian disinformation
and then it turned out to be true all of
it turned out to be true
and so you've got the intelligence
community the deep state the big tech
the corporations they've all got egg on
their face and they say okay gosh we
can't call it misinformation anymore
because it's true we can't call it
disinformation anymore huh
i know what we'll call it mal
information it's information that we
just think happens to be
bad for you
on covid if you if you say that the
death count's being exaggerated that's
misinformation no it's true okay it's
mal information it's information that we
don't like we look on it with a great
deal of malevolence fine speaking of
covid hillary clinton just came out
she
has some some bad news some scary news
but it's okay
it's good news in the end hillary has
covid
and so that's very scary right because
we've been told
covet is the most dangerous thing
ever in the history of the world but
it's okay she's tested positive but she
feels fine
she says quote
well
i've tested positive for kovid
i've got some mild cold
symptoms but i'm feeling fine i'm more
grateful than ever for the protection
vaccines can provide against serious
illness
please get vaccinated and boost it if
you haven't already now hold on a second
hold on speaking of misinformation i was
told at the beginning of the covid the
vaccine period of covid i was told that
the vaccines will prevent you from
contracting or transmitting
covid19
they changed their story later on later
on they said no it won't stop you from
getting coveted or transmitting it but
it will stop you from going to the
hospital
or it'll
it'll make it less likely that you go to
the hospital or less likely that you'll
die
that's what vaccines are for they
totally changed the definition of
vaccines but in the early part of the
vaccines dr fauci rochelle walensky joe
biden they all told us
these vaccines will stop you from
contracting covid or transmitting it
well now that turns out that's
misinformation they said it was
misinformation if you were skeptical of
that view that was mal information what
they said was misinformation and i just
it's so funny here how they keep moving
the goal post because and i've heard
this from many liberal friends of mine
liberal family members they'll say oh
michael you have to get the vaccine
you've got to get ten thousand boosters
it's so important kovid's really scary i
said i'm not really worried about covid
and i don't really
have all that much faith in the
experimental fouchy algae no michael you
have to get it it's so important and
then what happens two months later
they've got covid and i don't
and and i say hey how's that vaccine
working out for you and they say no well
you know i got covid because obviously
vaccines aren't supposed to stop you
from getting viruses that's never beep
boop bp boop
the the today the media tell tells me
that vaccines don't stop you from
getting beep beep beep boop so they
start repeating the the new media
narrative which contradicts their old
one they say but thank goodness i got
the vaccine
well what do you mean it looks like you
got covid anyway
well yeah but
it's kind of mild
yeah right kovid's usually mild and
healthy people it's generally extremely
mild no michael you don't thank goodness
i got the vaccine it would have been so
much worse if i didn't have the vaccine
oh yeah
would it
maybe
i'm not saying definitively no it would
be it wouldn't be worse if if you didn't
have the vaccine i don't know i'm not a
biologist okay i'm not an epidemiologist
but
here's what i do know the vaccine
doesn't do the thing that everyone said
it would do
furthermore the vaccine doesn't even
last that long that's why they told you
you only need to get one shot two shots
three shots four shots five shots we're
up to about five shots now
so it doesn't it's so effective that you
need to get five of them
the only reason you believe that it's
that kovid would be much worse if you
didn't have the vaccine is because the
same idiots who have been lying to you
and simply getting it wrong for two
years tell you that that's true but you
don't know these people have no
credibility at all frankly whatever
these people the fouchies the wallenskis
the binds whatever they tell me is true
on any given topic but particularly
covid i am inclined to believe and i
think it is a reasonable conclusion
to believe that the opposite
is true
uh yeah i've got co i've got 17 million
boosters i've got covid
don't forget to get the vaccine it's so
important and so is that is that so
hillary okay it's so important great you
know what i think you should do i think
you should just live a healthy life
eat healthy do the right thing
and you want to keep your iron up and
you want to have some good delicious
meat okay which is why you got to check
out good ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com knowles do you know
what i had for dinner last night do you
know what i had you know what i had for
dinner i had delicious good ranchers
burgers this was the wagyu beef blend
and it was so
freaking good i eat good ranchers at
this point probably two to three times
per week and it's such high quality the
prices are ridiculously reasonable not
just that you know you go to the grocery
store and you see all that lower quality
usually imported meat from these cheap
places overseas even though they pretend
to be american meat so you go there and
the price on that meat is going through
the roof right now
with good ranchers not only can you get
a 30 discount just for ordering today
you go to
goodranchers.com but if you subscribe
you will be locked into your price
forever so the price is already
extremely low and then if you lock in
today with inflation going through the
roof you will be locked in forever to my
favorite meet go to goodranchers.com
save on the quality you've been looking
for good ranchers takes the guesswork
out of the grocery store sources
everything from local forms farms rather
ships directly to your door use code
knowles enjoy your box of 100 american
meat 30 in savings
order now get that good american meat
delivered
speaking of information and covid
disinformation and misinformation we
have this series out right now fouchy
unmasked this was a little bit of a
stealth series we didn't promote it at
all we did there was no marketing there
was no advertising we'd been working on
it secretly for a while
just like those scientists in the wuhan
laboratory were working on certain
things secretly we were working on this
fouchy three-part docu-series secretly
and we just released it one day and i'm
so pleased to say the fouchy docu-series
is one of the most popular products we
have ever put out on the daily wire
this is uh just for members so if you
want to watch it you've got to head on
over and subscribe to the daily wire
we've gotten like a gazillion views i
mean it's done really really well it
just shows you
that
people
do not believe the narrative that they
have been sold on kovit what we were
told about kovid is dr fauci is the
science everything he says is true defer
to him everyone else is spreading
dangerous misinformation disinformation
he's the most important man in the
country he's the highest paid
employee of the federal government joe
biden said i will never fire him there
is no circumstance in which i will fire
him he was the democrat's golden boy and
now
even he is bad news for them and he's
coming back by the way
he's been doing this for two years he'll
be all over tv constantly changing his
mind and controlling your life and then
he'll disappear for a little bit
and then he'll just pop right back up
and try to control your life again and
he's doing it again he says oh as we're
like lightening up on the masks and the
vaccine mandates we're gonna have to
clamp down again there's a new variant
it's the alpha omega
delta lambda phi beta kappa variant
you've all got to lock down again
it's the phi beta cap you gotta all do
it now you sheep and so anyway we've uh
i'm really appreciative to people who
have gone and watched that series fauci
unmasked you got to go to the daily wire
to do it uh
become a subscriber today we've got the
untold story of fouchy unprecedented
information about him now is the chance
to make sure that this little jerk
doesn't come back again and further
destroy our society and our way of life
because they're going to try to do it
especially as the midterm elections come
around
now
the way our
government works is different than the
way
we were told it works in school for
those of us who are old enough to have
had civics class for those of us old
enough to have watched schoolhouse rock
i am a bill up on capitol hill
that's not the way our government really
works we think there are three branches
of government the executive and the
judiciary and the legislature and
there's a balance of powers and and a
separation of powers and checks and
balances and there's checks and balances
and separation between the federal and
the state and the local governments and
the people express their views and
through their elected representatives
they come up with laws and the president
decides to sign the laws or not and then
the judges rule on the law and interpret
the constitution
no
that's not that stuff happens sometimes
but the actual way that our government
works is that congress outsourced its
law-making authority to the executive
branch but not to the president it
outsourced its law-making authority to
the administrative agencies
earlier i when at the top of the show i
was talking about misdis
mal information that's from saisa
cyber security and infrastructure
security agency those guys make policies
the fda the cdc
the
abcd lgbt lmnop though those
institutions make policies and usually
they do so without any input from
lawmakers frankly not very much input
from the president and when there are
questions about their law making
authority it goes before the judiciary
usa usually the judges just defer to the
agencies
that's through a series of court
decisions notably chevron deference the
the courts will actually say okay well
you decide you determine agencies so
that's whether you say that's good or
whether you say that's bad that's just
the way our government works and if you
want to change the political structure
of our country that's where you got to
go that's why the fouchy of it all
matters that's why these bureaucrats
matter is they're the ones with the
power in
the government
speaking of the judiciary we have a
supreme court nominee who has just come
up for her confirmation hearings katanji
jackson
katanji jackson
on paper looks really good as far as a
left-wing nominee can she went to all
the right law schools she's got the
right pedigree so she's she's come up
before the senate but there are two
really disturbing aspects of her
background that republicans have honed
in on not that she had a beer at
georgetown prep with pj and swee and
brett kavanaugh back in the 80s not that
she gr groped someone at a party or
whatever other nonsense that the
democrats throw at republicans
it's about her actual judicial and
policy record the two problems with
katanji jackson are she's soft on child
pornography and she supports critical
race theory
senator cruz in particular
ted cruz focused in on this yesterday as
did
senator josh hawley who who really
zeroed in on some of katanji jackson's
defenses of why she went so light on
people guilty of crimes involving kitty
porn
you said to this defendant through whom
you sentenced to only three months in
prison
that your collection i'm quoting you
your collection at the time that you
were caught was not actually as large as
it seems
the government felt the need to respond
to you on the record they said the
government doesn't believe that it's
appropriate to just disregard the number
of images that the number of images can
be appropriate and indeed in this case
the defendant has amassed an extremely
large collection of child pornography
but you disregarded that you also told
the defendant you said this this seems
to be a case
where you were fascinated by sexual
images involving what were essentially
your peers
and then you went on to say the
defendant was merely trying to satisfy
his curiosity curiosity is your word
one more thing on this same idea you
said you were viewing this is you to the
defendant you were you were viewing sex
acts between children who were not much
younger than you and this whole
discussion is about why you're only
giving him three months
judge he was 18. these kids are eight
i don't see in what sense their peers
really good line of questioning from
hawley and ted cruz also pursued a
similar line of questioning
katanji jackson was arguing here that
the guy who has a ton of kitty porn
should basically get off the hook rather
than be in prison for 70 months 90
months even
two years he would only be in prison for
about three months because he's 18 and
18 year olds are basically the same as
eight-year-olds
an eighteen-year-old
is a freshman in college
an eight-year-old is in the third grade
if
if and a freshman in college
were hanging around with your third
grade child would you say oh well
little johnny he's just hanging around
with his peers
oh no where where is my eight-year-old
boy tonight oh he's just hanging out
with his peers over at the local
university no you wouldn't
there are some cases where there has
been debate on the left and the right
involving pornography and specifically
underage pornography cases like a 15
year old sends a picture of him or
herself
or receives a picture of
one of his classmates
and someone says well technically it's
child pornography
but
as katanji jackson was arguing it's
involving people's peers or themselves
so are you really going to charge some
13 year old kid
with producing child pornography because
he or she takes a nude selfie the same
as you would charge some 50 year old
gangster creep who's filming kids in
horrific situations no they're obvious
those are obviously different cases
there's obviously some there's some
ambiguity if it's a you know a kid on
some social media network making a
mistake when
he's a teenager or something with one of
his actual peers an 18 year old guy
with an eight-year-old with all of this
material that is a completely different
thing there is what katanji jackson has
tried to do is blur these lines on an
issue that is not blurry at all and so
holly and cruz were drawing stark
attention to that now why is katanji
jackson doing this is it because she's a
pedophile
no i don't think katan she's a pedophile
is it because she's just got a real soft
spot for pedophiles maybe maybe she does
i'm not sure but i suspect what it gets
to is something even deeper than that
which is that democrats always take the
side of the criminal to the complete
disregard and neglect of the victim you
see you see this with blm you see this
with antifa you see this with violent
criminals in all the american cities
right now you see this with all these
george soros installed district
attorneys they always take the side of
the criminal
and they never take the side of the
victims
this is why there are
rapes and assaults and murders going
through the roof right now in new york
city is because you'll get these
absolute animal degenerates out on the
street they've been arrested 50 times
they've got a rap sheet a mile long they
were arrested just a week ago and then
the da's say well because of bail reform
because because the only reason you're
committing these crimes is society and
how society has failed you we're just
going to let you out on the hook please
don't commit any more crimes than what
happens they do
i suspect that's what's going on here
and
frankly it's even more disturbing than
if katanji jackson just had some weird
sexual hang-up because it means that her
entire view of the law of crime of
justice is wrong it's perverted it
doesn't really make any sense and that
that is far from the craziest thing that
katanji jackson said during these
confirmation hearings we've got to
protect our system of government
our country and our homes which is why
you got to check out ring right now go
to ring.com
knowles you know about the ring video
doorbell it's amazing you can see and
speak to whoever is on your doorstep
whether you're in the house at the
office on the road on the other side of
the world you know that ring makes an
alarm maybe you didn't know that well
ring makes an award-winning alarm system
with available professional monitoring
well
ring makes the ring alarm
pro when you really want to take your
home security to the next level you've
got to go pro cnet calls ring alarm pro
a giant leap for home security after
using it i think they are absolutely
right it's so easy to install i'm not
the handiest guy in the world i
basically need to hire a contractor to
screw in a light bulb even i can install
it
ring alarm pro protect your entire home
and the wi-fi it runs on so now that we
live more of our lives online in virtual
space you want to protect both of it
your physical space your virtual space
nobody does this better than ring gopro
right now with rings award winning alarm
learn more at ring.com
knowles that is ring dot com slash
k-n-o-w l-e-s
about a year ago about a year ago
harry's razors responded to a tweet from
an account that had
two followers it was almost certainly a
liberal democrat operative account but
whatever some anonymous account and it
was an account that took issue with me
because of some very old clip where i
was on candace owns this old show on
another network on prageru and candace
had the audacity to say men are not
women or something like that i agreed
with it they they tag harry's and then
harry's
totally insults
our audience here harry's had been
sponsoring my show and they say oh this
is awful content it's vile we condemn
this we have a values misalignment
basically saying not just me but that
our entire audience is a bunch of bigots
they're awful horrible people and so we
here at the daily wire you know we do a
lot of things
make movies do politics we we do music
we do books
well
we also
we also make recipes okay and we've just
served up a dish called revenge and
revenge as the sicilians will tell you
is a dish best served cold we now have a
razor company called jeremy's razors
jeremy does not care about your politics
he doesn't he doesn't hate you i'm not
sure that he loves you but he doesn't
hate you okay he just he wants to give
you
a good razor
and he wants to shut up about
anything outside of that so we have got
the beautiful
daily wire jeremy's razor company go get
it today at ihateharrys.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
katanji jackson judge who's up for the
supreme court goes before
the senate
and the confirmation hearings are
revealing a lot of radicalism in this
woman so on the one hand she goes weak
on child pornography cases then the next
one this is frankly even crazier she
defends critical race
theory
senator cruz really nailed her down on
this issue you know the democrats always
try to get out of the critical race
theory stuff so they'll say on the one
hand i don't know what critical race
theory is critical race theory is not
being taught anywhere it doesn't matter
it's not a real issue and also i love it
and it's wonderful and it's good that
it's being
taught at one side of their mouth they
deny it completely out of the other side
of their mouth they exalt it and praise
it
senator cruz asks katanji jackson about
critical race theory about her views
there's a school that she's on the board
of in in washington
the school assigns these critical race
theory books
one of the claims in the books is that
babies are racist brought to you by
ibram kindy one of the the great
proponents of critical race theory
ideology in the country she says i don't
know what you're talking about
they include a book called anti-racist
baby
by abram kindly
and
their portions of this book
that that i find
really quite remarkable one portion of
the book
says babies
are taught
to be racist or anti-racist there is no
neutrality
another portion of the book
they recommend to babies confess
when being racist
now this is a book that is taught at
georgetown day school
to students in pre-k through second
grade so four through seven years old
um
do you agree with this book that is
being taught with kids that the babies
are racist i do not believe
that any child
should be
made to feel
as though they are
racist or though they are
not valued or though they are less than
that they are victims that they're
oppressors i don't
believe in any of that
i don't i don't believe in that i don't
i have no idea what these books are i
don't know i don't i see no evil hear no
evil absolutely
i don't know she's elsewhere she said i
don't really know what critical race
theory is i don't know anything about
this thing and that
is a lie
and it's interesting that cruz is the
one doing the grilling here because cruz
and katanji jackson went to law school
together they were one year apart in law
school they were on the law review
together and they went to harvard law
school harvard law school is the place
that critical race theory started so the
idea that katanji jackson who's on the
board of these schools that's pushing
critical race theory who's been in
left-wing legal circles for her entire
career the idea that she would have no
idea what critical race theory is is
simply beyond belief and and we know
that she supports critical race theory
because she's given speeches to law
schools university of michigan law
school among other places where she has
praised the founders of critical race
theory people like derek bell if you
know who derek bell is you know about
critical race theory okay
if you you you might know about critical
race theory even if you've never heard
of derrick bell or kimberly crenshaw or
the other intellectuals who developed
this but if you know their names you for
sure know what this is if you were
educated at the school that started
critical race theory and you are on the
left and you were there at the time that
this was really catching around
certainly you know what this is and so
what we've got here from katanji jackson
is a lie
she's lying about her views on critical
race theory she's lying about her
knowledge of critical race theory this
is really bad news if you're looking at
the future of the supreme court because
this is a woman who's extremely radical
and who is extremely dishonest so the
left is going into overdrive to try to
defend her they they suggest that any
time you bring up critical race theory
that's racist it's awful it's terrible
they're even saying that they're even
trying to defend her on the child
pornography front and the most hilarious
way to do that was on cnn
jeffrey tubin
a man known for
making love to someone that he loves you
know what i'm talking about a man known
for his
self-regard let's say and his lack of
judgment
jeffrey toobin
defended
the kiddie porn cases
i just had one point about these these
these kitty porn cases and this this
came up i remember when i was an
assistant us attorney back in the 90s is
that when those uh
when those uh sentencing guidelines were
written for those cases
that this was a time when
uh the people who committed these crimes
would order individual photos and and
and get and then get them usually
through email
and then
they would be sentenced based on the
number of photos they possessed this was
all pre-internet so uh once the internet
came in and and people got
access to hundreds and then thousands of
photos they would the the sentencing
guidelines would reflect hundreds and
then thousands of photos federal judges
have been struggling with the issue of
how do you create a fair system that was
designed pre-internet that was
yet you have to sentence people post
internet
jeffrey toobin this is just my advice to
you
as a
as a fellow person who goes on tv
as a fellow person who comments on
politics that is where the similarities
end by the way between me and jeffrey
tubin
sit this one out this is not this is not
a good issue for a man who famously had
to take a little break from his career
because of his sexual indiscretions
particularly involving
internet pornography
sit this one out
this is not a good case the point he's
making is somewhat interesting actually
a lot of conservatives are jumping on it
because he's basically saying because
this material is now more accessible we
need to change the sentencing guidelines
and that seems kind of silly on its face
but i actually think there's something
to it
if a man goes out and accumulates
hundreds of photos of child sexual abuse
material
and he does it by writing to
various murky mailboxes and collecting
this physical stuff and creating a place
for it in his home or wherever he's
storing it
that that actually does reflect a
different degree
of psychopathy and sickness
than does a guy who goes on a website
and downloads a million photos in a
second i actually i actually do think
he's making something of a fair point
here but then why is the
i i think the conclusion that jeffrey
toobin reaches is crazy because his
conclusion seems to be yeah and that's
why we need to be more lenient to the
people on child porn no if anything it
means you should probably be stricter it
means you should probably get them into
firmer rehabilitation because the
temptation now is so much stronger and
the accessibility is so much easier you
need
you need to be damn sure that they're
not going to be accessing this
in the future it was it's so much harder
to find an address to write to this
whole thing he's describing from the
early 90s it's so much harder to do that
than to go to www.sixstuff.com
and you know download a bunch of psycho
materials so yeah okay fine you got to
change the sentencing guidelines make
them harsher
make them tougher
at least make them more rehabilitative
but all that
even all of that is not the craziest
thing that judge katanji jackson said
during her confirmation hearings
the crt stuff the racist babies the
the kitty porn no
the craziest thing she said was in
response to republican senator marsha
blackburn
who asked katanji jackson a really
simple question this was not about some
really con contestable aspect of the law
some esoteric constitutional question no
the question was simple it is
can you define
what a woman is
can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no
yeah i can't
you can't
not okay this context i'm not a biology
of the word woman is so unclear and
controversial that you can't give me a
definition
this should be the end of her nomination
she should biden should pull the
nomination or she should withdraw
herself in disgrace she should leave the
legal community she should be disbarred
she should not have any role in public
life because i guess she's just a big
stupid idiot
here i thought she was an intelligent
woman she went to harvard she has had a
long career as a lawyer as a judge so i
thought she was reasonably intelligent
probably above average in her
intelligence in education but it turns
out she's just a big dumb stupid idiot
because she can't define the most basic
category
in humanity man and woman she can't
define it
and she's so
glib about it her she's got such a
blithe ignorance here she's so she's
gleeful and confident in her ignorance
uh
like a student in class first of all who
doesn't know the answer and is just
stalling for time
marcia says tell me what a woman is
and you define a woman and she repeats
the question
uh uh
you you want me to define what a woman
is uh yeah do you have
gunk in your ears you gotta stick a gum
in your ear yep yeah what's a woman
uh
um hold up um
no i can't define that
oh you can't define that
but no i can't define that i'm not a
biologist
i'm not a biologist
i
i'm not a meteorologist
i know when it's raining okay
i am not a um
gosh i don't know i'm not a an
astronomer
i know what the sun is
if you've made it through
if you've made it through
kindergarten i was going to say if you
made it through harvard law school
harvard undergraduate if you've made it
if you functioned as an adult in society
you should know it but no if you've made
it through
kindergarten
you should be able to say what a woman
is but this woman cannot do it she says
well i'm not a biologist
which raises another question if i find
a biologist who says that a woman is
a person who does not have
testicles
would you
would you then go along with that would
you accept that definition
a woman is a human being who is not a
man would you accept that definition
no of course you wouldn't she'd say that
biologist is a right-wing fake news
you support
lower sentencing for even pretty bad
criminals okay that's kind of par for
the course with democrats these days
with liberals okay it's bad but i get it
you support critical race theory and you
praise it by name and you support the
1619 project from the new york times
it's a lie that america was founded to
defend slavery it's completely made up
okay that's more radicalism that's
pretty bad
you can't tell me what a woman is
either katanji jackson is the stupidest
person in america
or she is among the most radical people
in america
and i don't think she's stupid
which means
katanji jackson is
at this point after her answer to marsha
blackburn she is by far the most radical
supreme court nominee ever to come
before
the united states senate to be confirmed
really spooky
stuff sexual disorder everywhere
and she's she's giving into this because
of course she is embracing the
transgender insanity that our entire
liberal elite are embracing you saw this
with nbc news you know william thomas is
this hulking dude who just beat all the
chicks at the ncaa swimming championship
and he's got broad shoulders and a big
adam's apple and a relatively deep voice
and i'm just talking about above the
belt okay you can use your imagination
or your google searches if you want to
see the other evidence for uh this
fella's masculinity so william thomas
wins the trophy and takes it away from
the chicks and he is not being condemned
as a cheater he is not being helped as
an obviously very disturbed man he no he
is being lauded by the liberal
establishment by nbc news
as
as jackie robinson as the jackie
robinson of transgenderism
headline leah thomas's ncaa championship
performance gives women sports a crucial
opportunity
yeah crucial opportunity not to exist
anymore that's that's the great
opportunity let me see if i can find
this quote yes here it is here it is
change in sports doesn't happen
overnight nor is it linear major
professional sports leagues like the mlb
and the nfl
resisted racially integrating their
player rosters it was not until 1962
that the last nfl team the washington
commanders would racially integrate
today athletes like jackie robinson are
celebrated as breaking the color barrier
in sports although that narrative often
requires sanitizing simplifying or
rewriting a more complex nuanced and
contradictory history
and so just like
when black people could play in the
white leagues now we've got men
competing in the women's leagues he's
like jackie robinson i actually think
will thomas is like jackie robinson they
have a lot of similarities
they're both
extremely muscular dudes who are good at
sports
so that's true
jackie robinson obviously much better in
his sport than will thomas is in his
sport and that is why will thomas isn't
breaking records in the men's league
for he competed in the men's league not
that long ago but he's breaking records
in the women's league because
because men and women are very very
different the difference between
white people and black people
and asian people and hispanic people i'm
not saying there are no differences
obviously there's some physical
differences things of course i'm not
denying that but the differences
are minuscule
compared to the difference between men
and women
the difference between men and women is
fundamental to our humanity
the difference between the races
is not fundamental to our humanity this
is why you have
in
in
all of the west certainly in modernity
since travel has been much easier since
uh people have moved around you you see
all sorts of different people of
different races go in and assimilate to
other cultures but men and women that
divide remains
pretty
pretty distinct
certainly much more distinct than
between the races
ron desantis ron desantis
is standing up against this craziness
this craziness of transgenderism in
sports
so officially will thomas who goes by
the name leah is the ncaa swimming
champion
not in the state of florida in the state
of florida
the girl
the girl
emma wyant is the women's champion
because ron desantis declared it so
if you look at what the ncaa has done
by allowing basically men to compete in
women's athletics in this case the
swimming
you had the number one woman who
finished was from sarasota emin wyant
she won the silver medal she's been an
absolute superstar her whole career she
trains i mean to compete at that level
is very very difficult and you don't
just roll out of bed and do it that
takes grit that takes determination and
she's been an absolute superstar and she
had the fastest time
of any woman in college athletics now
the ncaa
is basically taking efforts to destroy
women's athletics they're trying to
undermine the integrity of the
competition and they're crowning
somebody else uh the woman's champion
and we think that's wrong and so in
florida we're going to be doing a
proclamation uh saying
that emma
is the best female swimmer in the 500
meter freestyle because she earned that
i love that this is an excellent use of
government because what the libs will
say is
this is crazy ron desantis doesn't have
the right to do that he doesn't have the
authority to do that
but why not
well the ncaa is the authority you're
right the ncaa has some authority which
it is squandering right now it's
squandering all of its credibility by
pretending that men are women
i think ron desantis has some authority
too i think he's the governor of florida
i think he's actually got a great deal
more authority given to him by the
people of florida than the ncaa has
and so sure the ncaa is using their
authority to declare this dude the
greatest female swimmer in america
and ron desantis is using his far more
credible authority to declare
the young girl
the greatest female swimmer in america
better than the man who is pretending to
to be that title
yeah i think this is a great use of
government power
sometimes we feel on the right like we
don't have any power whatsoever anymore
because the libs control the
corporations and the media and big
technology and the administrative state
which has so much control over our
government and they control they control
every powers of the universities they
control every power center in the
country
the one power center that we
occasionally still can control
is elective office and conservatives
have put themselves at a huge
disadvantage a potentially fatal
disadvantage
by taking this radical libertarian
almost anarchist line that it's always
bad to use the government government
power is always bad well that government
power is the only power that we can ever
even sometimes occasionally get we've
lost every other power center for
goodness sakes we lost the military
we lost the cia the cia now is putting
out is p putting out documentaries or
commercials about its members where they
say i'm an intersectional latinx
feminist
radical they join join me
young pansexual transsexual whatever and
then the army the us army is putting out
recruitment videos saying i learned how
to be a fighter it's some young girl and
she says i learned how to be a fighter
when my lesbian guardians took me to a
pride parade when i was 10.
so that's gone those other institutions
of power are gone
the one we have occasionally is elected
government we should use that power not
in an unjust way not in a tyrannical way
not in an autocratic way but we should
use that power justly for the good for
the true and the beautiful we don't have
any other option the only other option
is lie down and take it lie down and
give away your whole culture and let the
culture be completely destroyed that's a
very bad
idea now speaking of elected leaders
you got a really good one down in
florida you got a really good one a
really terrible one
up in
boston this is this this mayor of boston
is sort of the anti-desantis he's
probably the best executive leader in
america right now this woman is one of
the worst
and she just came out
and this was on her st patrick's day
breakfast and she was complaining about
the snow and she said you know don't
worry she's used to dealing with
problems
that are that are disruptive and white
in just over a hundred days we have
connected unhoused residents at mass and
cast to housing treatment and services
we've launched three free bus lines
we've taken some big bold actions but i
won't lie
this past winter was pretty intense
trial by snow
trial by fire fighters union
i'm getting used to dealing with
problems that are expensive disruptive
and white
i'm talking about snowflakes snowflakes
i mean snowstorm snowflakes
not exactly don rickles okay not she's
not quite a rodney dangerfield is she
she's got to work on that comedic timing
and i i think she should work on her
material
her material the actual content of
herman here's the this was the joke i
hate white people that's the joke white
people are terrible i hate them
i i'm an asian woman and i hate white
people
hahaha white people are bad
we are told in this very
stupid and deluded culture we are told
that white people are privileged and
everyone else is oppressed
in reality the opposite is true the only
group that it is legal to discriminate
against is white people in some cases
you can also discriminate against asians
who get lumped in with white people for
some reason ironic given this woman's
joke
but it's really primarily white people
that are permitted to be discriminated
against on the social scene the only
race that you can criticize that you're
actually encouraged to criticize and
mock and deride on the basis of race is
white people so
the the narrative that we are told is
the opposite of what is actually going
on in reality
there's such an irony here i mentioned
just a few moments ago
that the difference between the races is
really relatively minor compared to the
difference between the sexes
you know
christianity is quite clear about this
right there is uh
neither june nor greek nor slave nor
free but all are one in christ jesus the
the racial difference is really
not all that significant sexual
difference still is is quite significant
right in in the beginning there there
was man
male and female uh god created them and
yet what we're told today
is exactly the opposite it's a total
inversion
of christianity of our religious
tradition we are told that the
difference between men and women
basically doesn't exist and the
difference between the races is
insurmountable you see this
everywhere that this
liberal ideology leftist radical call it
whatever you want
it seems always not just to distort but
to totally invert
our traditional understanding of our
culture and it's true here on race and
sex traditionally
race less significant sex much more
significant here you totally flip it
this is a great example
of uh misinformation okay it's something
that's actually just not true and yet we
are told that the very true statements
that we make whether it's about sex or
crime or justice or society or whatever
basic biology we're told that that is a
fake news terrible if it's even if it's
true it's mal information and they need
to shut us up i'm michael knowles it's
the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
john bickley here daley wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire
on today's episode the cdc reduces the
covet death count the ukraine war takes
a toll on the wheat supply and the
drought in california adds to the
growing food crisis
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire